Butler now with a quick eight point
quarter
lose good defense by the Thunder the
lead pass comes out and the bucket is
checked in gets his first two
have done that by committee but he's a
guy who could really get the Jazz in the
what they want to do offensively that's
a big move yeah that's a big move
acquire who is Left-Handed needs that
pumping again there's a left hand he
drew them to his right and he used his
left took the spill but he gets back up
Jalen Williams the Santa Clara Jalen
Williams at 21. the lead all scorers
Holmgren has eight in his pocket looking
to make it 10 and drops it from about 12
feet out right now Utah five and 16 from
downtown
he shot 34 last year and he's been on
fire tonight oh for six to start this
third quarter and in the meantime the
Thunder have gone 8-0 on the Run make it
oh for seven and in transition and easy
easy put down by holgren
dig into that bag
ochai puts his shoulder down races to
the racket to get another home run now
with 14 points
blocks that shot of George Well I like
this
fundamentally sound block right here not
just one hand but going up vertical is
set homegrown with two hands